and of course what it all clarified was
the fact that the
antifa activists are have a very clear
policy which is that they want to
provoke
the police or need any law enforcement
into something they can pretend is an
act of violence that they can catch on
camera and use
as an explanation for the allegedly
fascist nature of the american state
so you left los angeles i said goodbye
to you and you said i'm going to
portland
and i said why are you going to portland
and i think you said
i need to see it for myself so you went
up to portland
yes what do you see up in portland
i slightly shot my bolt on this because
i wrote a piece for one of the papers
saying california's if california's a
failed state
and then i went to oregon
um yeah yeah um
portland is some people say to me you
know why do you need to go and see this
stuff for yourself and i just think it's
it's an instinctive curiosity i have and
i also
even when it is exactly what you think
it is going to be
it's still interesting you know
portland oregon was exactly what i
feared it would be but a bit worse
i was horrified by the immigration of
the city
the total destruction of all public
monuments and public buildings
the shuttering up of shops intimidation
of the citizenry
the demoralization of the citizenry a
homelessness problem which makes even
california's look
minimal um and the fact that the city's
basically been given over
to an admiserated lawlessness
i went with antifa
several nights in a row uh to
pardon the language a [ __ ]
gentrification protest
which was my first yeah that was your
first one
yeah it was yes i've heard the two
always avoided the temptation
i i quite like gentrification actually i
think i think that
houses being made nicer and neighborhood
being smarter is no bad thing but
old-fashioned view uh certainly not the
viewer of antifa in portland who
sectioned off some of the streets and
went through them in the middle of the
night
screaming at the citizens and the house
owners telling them they were all stay
here on stolen land
this included many black families by the
way uh shouting at these black
families white families families of
every background shouting at them they
were on stolen land and um
and should get out were you worried were
you worried for your own safety i mean
you were you were out there with them i
mean
people know who you are yes i was
um lucky enough that in the era of mask
wearing you can cover almost your entire
face
uh lawfully indeed almost compulsively
and um uh i was uh
i mean i've been in worse places and war
zones where
there's more lawlessness than that but i
i i
it was not in a pleasant situation to be
in what is nominally a first world city
um the second night i went with them to
the protest at the ice facility where
um which was a bit hairier because they
were assaulting the studies one of the
very few
um federal buildings in the in the area
uh they play a game of cat and mouse
with law enforcement
they get closer and closer to the front
of the building their aim in the past
has been to barricade in the buildings
put burning dumpster trucks in front of
them and then kill the people inside by
burning them
alive so that's their modus operandi so
you can understand why the ice officers
don't want that
and they get within a certain uh
closeness to the door
and then the uh officers break out and
uh there was firing tear gas uh pepper
bullets
and all that and people were selling
fire things in the street
and uh and that was that was uh
unpleasant yes
i got um
you know shoot out of an alleyway
by federal officers with a bunch of
other antifa with me and
the officers at gunpoint you know told
us please to move
out of the alleyway and it was
unpleasant but i have to say that
considering the situation i thought the
officers were as as decent and
reasonable and um efficient in their
duties as they could possibly be
and of course what it all clarified was
the fact that
the antifa activists
are have a very clear policy which is
that they want to provoke
the police or need any law enforcement
into something they can pretend
is an act of violence that they can
catch on camera and use as an
explanation for the allegedly fascist
nature of the american state
um they are it was very interesting
to see these activists up close i
thought they were all
um reprehensible people i thought they
were clearly
mentally in a very unstable place
i thought that furthermore on election
night in washington dc when i saw antifa
um gathering in the doorways just
outside the north lawn of the white
house the world's press were pointing
their cameras at the white house
and beside them underneath some of the
doorways i saw what was clearly antifa
gathering because they
were changing into clothes so that they
couldn't be recognized by
cctv cameras uh went over to
film this because it was clear this was
what was going on and they became very
violent very fast
and uh they are thugs they're a
paramilitary group
they have no place in a democracy um
it's to america's shame that they've
been allowed to do
what they have been doing they
threatened to kill journalists
they had graffitied kill andy no
mutual friend and journalist and
reporter in portland oregon
they had repeated calls to murder him
across
the city um uh the fact that they can
then intimidate a journalist
from abroad who even has the map the
tenacity
to try to capture them on a video camera
or
look at what they're doing is very bad
it's an embarrassment for america i
think the whole thing is an
embarrassment
did you get a sense that when you're on
the ground with him that there
is a leader because you know this is
what joe biden described antifa as an
idea and partly what i think it seems to
be is that there's no sort of
known leader sort of by design but when
you're out there with these groups dc
portland wherever you are could you
sense like oh somebody's actually in
charge or is it just like this roving
gang yeah
no of course they have a leadership uh
andy knows forthcoming book will reveal
a lot about this
um but yes of course they have a
leadership uh
they don't gather like uh moisture or
something i mean it's
uh they are brought together they are
organized they
advertise within their own groups what
they're going to do and when what their
actions are they tell people
what to bring or what not to bring what
to say and what not to say what to chant
and what not to chant and
uh and yeah i mean they they they do the
whole thing
they're an organized group and by the
way one of the one of the most haunting
things for me was
uh i mean i i'm among others i
interviewed lots of people on my travels
including
black police officers in oregon who i
think were some of the most
the bravest most remarkable and i
thought
um restrained people i've ever met
but one of the conversations that
haunted me even more than that
was speaking to an owner of a restaurant
in
a cafe in portland who had
just recently had just the day before
had had bullets
live ammunition but it's fired through
the windows of his his business
because he it seemed because he has
photos on the wall of um
first responders a woman a woman soldier
a u.s soldier a man
in fireman's uniform and this apparently
makes him a
representative of the fascistic american
state thus
live ammunition is fired by antifa blm
activists through his business
uh by the way he is a is a black
american a very proud patriot
and he said to me actually we talked
about this i said to him
you know what do you think of the uh of
the them
presidential contender joe biden's claim
that it's just an idea
and he pointed to the bullet holes in
his business his windows and he said
but an idea doesn't fire bullets
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell